you know the Bay Area is a very special
place I'm i grew up in Palo Alto as well
and then yeah very what I wanted to move
to LA actually I remember a guy in a
store telling me oh no don't go there
you'll be back you'll be back don't
worry oh yeah and I'm still in LA but I
do miss it but I didn't at the time but
the Bay Area is a very special place
what do you think how could you describe
it to people that aren't from there
because it is there some openness to it
yeah i think the landscape is very
exciting um it's very beautiful and it's
also kind of there's this like
interesting border between suburbia and
wilderness that I explore in the movie
um and also like a lot of like
interesting characters um so no movie
there's like a lot of like it takes
place in 1985 and there's like a number
of kind of like hippie weirdo character
it's like left over from the 70s so that
was really fun to like write all those
characters and some of them are from the
stories and then I added a few but it's
yeah there's like I think there's a good
Bay Area personality in terms of that
interesting mix of like hippies and then
more like Tom Silicon Valley like
technology um sort of more entrepreneurs
types so there's an interesting like
tension and mix of people I'd say um
yeah that's a great and I remember when
they would do free Grateful Dead shows
like a rat and the town we just converge
which is all these characters young and
all that it was just a really enjoyable
hot room and a lot of grateful dead when
I was writing good og to relax me one of
the bull I did kind of get into them I
don't know is weirdly but also one of
James's stories that he had talked about
me adapting it's called friend of the
devil oh right but that song and so
there's like a character um character
who's obsessed with the devil i guess
but i think it has to do with that kind
of no local character um and the
characters obsessed with the devil meets
this older veteran and
I don't know positive that you know kind
of like weird 70s leftover subcultures
that are still there even though it's a
very wealthy area um so yeah I like the
Grateful Dead and is it correct that
Jerry Garcia actually lived in Palo Alto
is a map well when I was does I think
that's true and when I was doing
research for the film to kind of see
what was going on in technology in the
80s I read a lot of books that talk
about how um you know kind of like Steve
Jobs is known for having this hippie who
went on things like trips to India
there's a lot of like the early
technology people that were into the
counterculture so you read I read about
a lot of like people who hung out with
jerry garcia and then like invented the
first computer um and there's a little
bit of that in the film because a lot of
the dads work in tech so there's one dad
for example that spends all his time on
the well which is this like early
internet chatroom that's kind of like I
think had some like Grateful Dead
connections and was kind of a sub
cultural thing and then developed into
the internet um so there's I was trying
to like we've that background in to the
movie of like what was going on before
we had the internet and no exploring
personal connections as they were
changing in that time um so sorry that's
kind of a digression from no that's fact
I remember yeah IBM going on school
field trips to like seeing the first
computer which was like whole room it
was like this huge room of these
machines not that I need to interview
you then I want to know more yeah well I
mean it was cool there was a lot of
interesting stuff in there and there is
that neat mix of to sort the bohemian
versus the sort of the left brain techie
yeah that's what a person and I think
they don't think of themselves as
opposed to one another they actually
think they're kind of their related like
there were a lot of like counterculture
people who became these crazy tech
geniuses and it's yeah it's pretty
interesting